la ciudad de san paolo se ha convertido
en el epicentro mundial de la muerte y
la formosa es el cementerio más grande
de américa latina'
los entierros se suceden sin parar es un
ir y venir de su cultura eros y féretros
esta familia acaba de enterrar a su
abuela el administrado el hospital ella
fue ingresada con algunos problemas de
salud y en el hospital fue diagnosticada
también con kobe esta mañana tuve un
paro cardíaco y no resistió la décima
parada kutcher
la presión sobre el sistema funerario es
tanta que ha sido necesario transformar
los autobuses escolares en carros
fúnebres
al atardecer una empresa especializada
enciende los ojos para que los
enterradores puedan seguir trabajando
las sepulturas son realizadas con
rapidez
no hay una área reservada a los
fallecidos por kobe pero constatamos que
son la mayoría
este albañil perdió a su cuñado el
entierro nocturno no fue su elección ha
sido una propuesta del ayuntamiento hay
muchos sepelios y ellos han prolongado
el horario nos ha tocado a las 21 horas
este fue el horario en que nos dejaron
venir
el aumento descontrolado de las muertes
preocupa el sector de los sepultureros
en un año el número de entierros en san
paolo se ha duplicado y el trabajo
también este líder sindical explica que
hay que sumar constantemente los cuerpos
para ganar espacio en el cementerio
desde hace muchos años exigimos que el
ayuntamiento amplíe el servicio en sao
paulo
construir cementerios verticales y más
crematorios si las muertes continúan
aumentando a este ritmo sin duda
podremos llegar a ver un colapso del
sistema funerario de hoy de un colapso
luto serbios vulnerados y gestionar
tantas muertes supone un alto coste
físico y emocional este sindicalista
denuncia la falta de apoyo psicológico y
la escasa protección de los empleados
subcontratados